Speaker 1: All right. Let's get caught up about
a number of goings on in the American political
world. Hillary Clinton is never running for
president again. This is what she is now
saying. And this is interesting because there
has been increasing speculation not only from
some on the left who are sort of skeptical of the
establishment Democratic Party, but also from many
on the right who seem convinced that at some point
Hillary Clinton will return in 2024, will be a
rematch between Trump and Clinton. Hillary Clinton
is now very directly saying she is not running for
president again. She was interviewed by Norah
O'Donnell. She was asked the question directly
and then maybe more interestingly, she was asked,
well, then what about if Trump runs in 2024? Let's
take a look at this. This is pretty interesting.
Speaker 2: Hillary Clinton is on a new campaign of
sorts with her daughter Chelsea for a new Apple TV
Plus docu series highlighting extraordinary women.
It's called Gutsy. We sat down exclusively with
the former secretary and asked her, what's next?
Would you ever run for president again? No.
No. But I'm going to do everything I can
to make sure that we have a president who
respects our democracy and the rule of law
and upholds our institution. What if Donald
Trump runs again? He should be soundly defeated.
It should start in the Republican Party, grow a
backbone, stand up to this guy, and heaven forbid
if he gets the nomination, he needs to be defeated
roundly and sent back to Mar a Lago, the Florida
mansion now in the spotlight after an affair.
Speaker 1: So she's being very clear here.
She's not running for president again. Now,
those who are committed to the idea of some
conspiracy to install Hillary Clinton or whatever,
they will say that she still might run, but
I believe her. It seems very clear that she isn't
running. And I think that this is correct. I don't
think that she should run again. She would have
been a better president than Trump. I voted for
her. But I believe that the window has passed. And
I think it's the same thing with Bernie Sanders,
quite frankly, even though I know there
are many in my audience who don't like it
when I say that and when I say this, I am not
speaking. You know, I want to remind everybody,
one of the ways in which I hope the left is
different from the right is that we don't
deify candidates. Trump often will say, I don't
know that Joe Biden has anybody running around
with a Biden hat or a Biden shirt or whatever.
Yeah, because on the left, my desire is that we
see elected officials just as people with whom
we hopefully agree on more than we disagree,
and we vote for them and then we move on with
our lives. In other words, the right has these
cult of personality. Sometimes the left does too.
And sometimes when I say I think Bernie's time has
passed, people will get very angry with me because
they see Bernie almost as as a sort of deity.
I voted for Bernie in the primary, and Hillary
ended up being the nominee. I voted for Hillary
in the general, but she lost. I would vote for
either of them over Trump or DeSantis or whoever.
But I think both of them, despite me voting for
them, are now beyond running for president. And I
mean, listen, maybe Hillary should run for special
master and could review those documents. No,
I'm kidding. But I believe this is the right
decision. I believe it is, really. You know,
it's been said for a while now, really? Since
Obama is I guess so a while, six years. It's
been said for a period of time now that overall
the Democratic Party needs to look younger in its
ranks for presidential candidates. I think that
Hillary recognizes that. I think Bernie recognizes
as well. I don't think either is going to
run for the Democratic nomination in 2024.
And there really are lots of good people around.
And I've talked about many of them. And I would
like to see some some other new people run. And
we'll have plenty of time to talk about that